uh briefly as um if you're uh if you're
dead set and just arguing about the
early church then I'll just leave but go
ahead I'm interested like to argue about
whether Trinity is in the Hebrew Bible
I'd love to debate you on that most
definitely I'd like to debate you on
that one all right cool awesome you know
Hebrew right I do indeed precisely
that's why you're gonna make my case for
me okay so no you will I'm do exactly
the opposite uh I'll bet you will I mean
let's not be arrogant be a little humble
brother because I want to be nice to you
all right sure first of all as an
orthodox Jew who is the Holy Spirit to
you the holy spirit is a uh is is a is a
way that God um man that God
um relates and uh what's the word um
it's it's it's a way that God interacts
with the with the
world so then why do you have toic
reference where the holy spirit is
speaking to your God I'm going to show
you because it's a it's a way of
interaction with hear my question repeat
my question what was my question
question you asked was why is it that in
our vinck texts it talks about the Holy
Spirit speaking to people no and I
didn't say that no I thought that's what
you said sorry no I said the Holy Spirit
speaking to your God speaking to
speaking to God it's a it's it's really
it's really it's really an allegory of
uh of of different different aspects of
God speaking uh to different aspects of
god good example I'll give I'll give you
an example where where where this when
this comes into play one of our prayers
um that we say on uh on some fast days
uh we start speaking as it were to God's
attribute of Mercy now if you know about
um about Jewish uh Orthodox Jewish
theology um you know that you know that
we don't actually believe that God has
Eternal attributes that uh that that are
real and so and so what does it mean
when we speak to the attribute of Mercy
it means that we're speaking to the way
that God relates to the world
in fashion Joshua let's have a
discussion no preaching so these are not
real attributes they're fake attributes
okay number one tell people that what
you believe in a you tell them explain
that what you believe because I'm going
to show you in your in your T but I want
people know that you believe in what
they call the sorry for my
mispronunciation S and the
10 yes okay so I want people to know
Rabbi Judaism has been mixed in with
Gnostic teaching and they think it's
based on the T could you also confirm
for everyone I just want everyone to
know this so I'm not putting words in
your mouth that you also believe in
transmigration of the souls that you do
accept the type of reincarnation
um it's it's it's debated amongst the
rabbis but that is the that is the
general view s Gan disagrees with this
but this is the generally held view
generally held it's because one voice
the sense doesn't mean all voices the
sense so I'm I'm glad you're honest so
now I want to ask you this question you
admit that it's one aspect of God
speaking to the other aspect of God
right yes good so a literal thing um
none of the rabbi interpret this as none
of the commentaries um interpret these
these MIM as as literal um they they
they interpret as as teaching a certain
type of allegorical lesson okay
it's yeah but but the uh but the literal
read is different aspects okay it's
irrelevant whether you take it literally
or allegorically even if we with your
interpretation what is it telling you
what are you supposed to learn from the
spirit speaking to God so God is
speaking to himself in a different
moment
what are you supposed to learn from that
well it it really depends on which
aspects that it mentions usually when it
mentions God just um just as uh as we
would say Stam as a just God in in in
the name itself so that usually refers
to God in terms of a merciful god and
usually the Holy Spirit um refers to
refers to God in in an attribute of
judgment and so we have sorry uh let me
rep my question I don't think you got it
no no I'm explaining the reason I'm
answering you so the reason why you'll
have the two speaking to each other
right in a in a mid in a mid in an
allegory which is what a mid really is
um that's the meaning of the word um is
uh is is because it's it's teaching
about a discussion between between the
merciful aspect and the and the Judgment
aspect so these attributes are being
personified so either you're telling me
that here we have a case where
attributes are speaking as of their
persons and they're not and I'm still
trying to figure out then what are you
supposed to learn from this fictional
discussion between attributes and our
persons which you didn't answer you just
repeated that it depends on the specific
it depends on specific passage the Holy
Spirit kept crying enough preaching
Lamentations rabba 360 the Holy Spirit
kept crying you have seen oh Lord the
wrong done to me
so now allegorize this for me why is the
holy spirit crying out to the
Lord I'm not familiar with this
particular passage I'll be honest I'll
have to have a look at the commentaries
if you hold on just a second that's fine
okay because Med is something that we
use commentaries to understand yeah let
me see if I can find
it9 right yeah limitation
3 we find it yeah yeah hold on a second
let me see if I can get an online try
try to interact I don't want to hear Too
Much pring I'm not preaching I'm just uh
just here to
explain
um hold on
second you on the same thing I am yeah
I'm trying to find the the RBA for you
limitations so Safari I use this as well
you're not the only one yeah
okay okay well three what was it was it
360 or 36 where the Holy Spirit cries
out sorry where the Holy Spirit cries
out yeah I'm looking for
that
thing let me
see in the meantime while they're
getting this together everybody just go
ahead and hit the like button as you
guys are coming in helps the stream hit
the algorithm so everybody smash the
like button like if you're Disobedience
go ahead and
434 strike it right in its mouth all
right everybody hit that like button we
got almost 2,000 people in here already
so let's get the likes up to 2,000
ladies and
gents okay if you can't find it that's
fine I'll give you others but I haven't
found it yet okay that's fine okay well
have you managed to find it in the I'm
not going to be able find it either but
uh I I do
have this uh check that should be
probably easier to look through yes and
right here I just W to Psalm five well I
okay you can yes I have it here quoted
the Hebrews here I quote it accurately I
just want the Holy Spirit responds and
says to cause those who love me to
inherit substance so you believe the
Holy Spirit speaks right yeah in uh in
in in a manner of speaking yes yeah he's
speaking right in a manner of speaking
the Holy Spirit speaks I don't know what
manner of speaking is either he speaks
or he doesn't like God speaks so God
speaks in a manner so you admit the Holy
Spirit has a personal Dimension
right um in the same way that God does
yeah well thank you you're now one step
closer to the Trinity good job I thought
you're going to refute me good so you
admit that the Holy Spirit has a
personal mention in the same way that
God does so now because it's an aspect
God okay and that aspect is a personal
aspect is it a personal aspect that it
can interact with
God in the way that God interacts with
with himself yes so when God interacts
with himself is he really interacting in
a way that there is a differentiation
within God so that these different
aspects they are personal aspects that
truly interact or are you saying God is
a schizoph Fric neither it's a it's it's
a way in it's a way in which that in
reality it's not actually happening but
it's a thing Al it's fake it's not
reality so can let me finish my sentence
please not if you're
get I thought you gonna be polite let me
finish my sentence okay go Ahad um it's
not that it it's not that the they're
talking to that God is talking to
himself in reality because God has no to
talk himself in in reality all that this
is is the rabis teaching us lessons
about God
by speak to himself Josh you know I cut
you up because you repeated the same
point five times but you haven't refused
you haven't actually argued against the
point I've made yes I have because you
said God is not speaking in reality so
let me repeat my objection so when God
gives you the Jew the impression that
the spirit is speaking and interacting
with him you're saying that's not
reality so he's play
acting you said it's not reality so what
lesson am I supposed to learn without
your rabbis brainwashing me to say no
this is not real if I read the text and
I have the spirit interacting with you
and with God and God is an act of spirit
without your rabbis brainwashing me this
is the
rabbis you're quoting the rabis are you
cutting me off no I'm quoting their
admission the spirit Speaks now their
explanation is not what I'm endorsing do
you understand the difference okay so
let me repat who say who's
saying says it in the passage you have
right
there the says in her left hand Rich is
and honor in length of days what he say
did he say this is not love substance
that's his interpretation where does he
say it's not
reality where did he say it's not a
reality he's interpreting the the left
hand as as a
as as as one thing and the right hand is
another thing no well my right hand is
not my left hand but where did he say
when the spirit responds and says to
cause those who love me to inherit
substance where does he say that's not
reality huh it's in front of me show me
where you just said what he
said that in the medis never the medis
never speaks and and explains itself
that's not what a medish does totaling
of what a med is can we go back to the
first okay Josh let's go back to the
first point you just confirm what I said
that if I just read this without your
Rabbi commentary because you just said
to everyone's being recorded that this
is not explaining itself that's exactly
my point M so if I don't let your rabbis
brainwash me in order not to see what
this plainly says then the plain reading
is the spirit is a person not like you
and me I'm not saying he's Flesh and
Blood distinct from God who interacts
with God and with with Israel that was
my point I don't need your RBI
interpretation I want the plain reading
of the
text right here plain reading I don't
need your rabbis I don't believe them
just like you don't believe my Christian
rabbis so if I deal with the text and
put it your commentary in mine even a
blind man can see the spirit is personal
he speaks and engages he can be grieve
and he speaks with God that's now a step
closer to the Trinity I have a question
for you good in this passage you say
that the holy spirit is it now I'm I'm
not I'm not going to contradict what you
said I'm just asking where do you
actually see in this specific passage
that the holy spirit is speaking to
speaking to God oh I didn't say here it
was the other one limitations rabba
right but but you are saying it about
this one no no said the Holy Spirit
speaks and the Holy Spirit responds and
says if I'm responding that means I'm
hearing and
interacting to cause those who love me
that's a personal pronoun last time I
checked a me yeah okay so I don't care
how your rabbis interpret just like you
don't care how my Christian Scholars
interpret it
okay commentary that is what is at the
end of the
day I'm going to ask you a third time
because we're spending week
can you show me in this passage where
your
Rabbi allegorized this I know that you
have rabbis that try to allegorize
statements here where does he explain it
the way you did to try to get around
it well because because when you look at
at the at the verse that he's that he's
interpreting here you see that what he
says has very little to do with the
verse itself therefore it is an allegory
of the
verse yeah I didn't ask for your
explanation I asked for his stop reading
into him what you think he means now the
Heavenly voice is the Heavenly voice an
allegory the bat that you rabbis refer
to is that an actual voice that you can
hear from God the basal is is is it
literally means a daughter of a voice
which means that it's U which means that
it's um it's like a prophecy but less
than a prophecy yes I I know that but is
it you allegorize that or you going to
believe that it's actually God speaking
in some sense I'm not saying he speaks
like me it's it's not it's not it's not
the direct word of God it's the indirect
word of God and is it God indirectly
speaking yes or
no yes indirectly good good because
according to what I just read
here the Heavenly voice is the holy
spirit
speaking Yeah it's right it's something
which is less than prophecy which is why
which is which is why if you look at
other parts of the uh of of the rinic
Canon you can see that uh that prophecy
is the is the is the top level of of
communication between man and God the
second level down is regular Holy Spirit
talk and the third level down is um is
the basal okay maybe I wasn't clear
according to this Source the batle is
the holy spirit
speaking which part you didn't get the
Heavenly voice it says this is where the
Holy Spirit spoke three
times here Rabbi alar said that the Holy
Spirit appeared in three places in the
court of Shem as it says and Judah
recognized and said she is more
righteous than I perhaps he did not say
this but rather someone else said it in
his presence a Heavenly voice went s
went forth and said here's a second time
she is more righteous than he in the
court of Samuel as it says here I am
test ify against me before the Lord and
before his anointed and they said you
have not defrauded us a hly voice went
forth and said he is telling the truth
in the matter in the court of Solomon as
it says 1 Kings 3:26 give her the living
child and by no means kill her kill him
she is his mother a Heavenly voice went
forth and said she is his mother so
according to your rabbis in these three
passages she is his mother that was the
Heavenly Voice who is the Holy
Spirit yeah I I suppose you're right
okay I'm glad you're at least being
honest I appreciate that because I want
to get off of this I want to go into the
plurals in the Hebrew but here's another
one all
right and if you say that you lose
Nothing by doing so beware for the Holy
Spirit cries out and says Proverbs 21:23
he who guards his mouth and his tongue
guards his soul from trouble so we've
already established you've already
agreed with me the holy spirit is a
personal aspect that's why he can speak
so we don't need to debate that right
yeah sure okay all right that's good now
I'm going to use kab.org because I don't
want to use a Christian translation
because you're going to say ah Christian
translation butchering it all right okay
let's go here and you to read the Hebrew
right sure oh
okay I know what your answer is going to
be but I want people to hear it for
themselves okay all right right
here now let me see let me I have to do
you have it because I got to oh let me
make this screen a little smaller I have
it I have it okay now you admit that
here elim
right yeah okay so we're not gonna
debate it's a spirit of God so you have
Elohim and the spirit of God
right now this verb
hovering yeah you know it's used one
other place right in
the just see if I can remember I'll tell
you where here I'll get it for you omy
3211 because I'm want to see I want to
see if you're and I I give you a benefit
that you're honest you're not just for
pics Deuteronomy
talking hold on a
second yeah says okay so I want everyone
so here it's liking God to an eagle that
hovers over its fledglings right does it
say that about God yeah so the Lord
guided them alone and there was no alen
does
okay so we agree now here it says the
Lord is being likened to an eagle that
hovers over its fledglings I want to see
if you understand the metaphor the
metaphor of an eagle hovering over its
nest that's because it's going to
protect the nest and provide for those
in the nest
right because it's lik God doing that
for you in the desert
think for a second yeah read it so you
don't think I'm making it up I'm just
thinking I'm let me think for a second
go go ah Josh know right go
ahead yeah so Eagles obviously is a type
of bird so they uh so they look after
they look after their um their their um
their b the baby birds yep um and the
way they do that is they is they hover
over them um make sure that uh that the
prey don't come and take them or that
nothing happens but that shows Awareness
on the part of the because Eagle must
know that's her nest and not someone
else's Nest right yeah so that shows
that the eagle has awareness of course
okay I'm glad you're man you you're I'm
starting to respect you a lot more and
because it has awareness it's aware
these are my young I have to protect
them right yeah all right now let's go
back to Genesis 1
what does it say about the spirit then
because it uses the same verb what does
this imply about the spirit's
cognition I see I see what you're trying
to say you're trying to say that because
it uses the word hovering that therefore
it also implies awareness now I'm not
going to deny that the spirit of God
which I don't see as distinct from God
as um is aware I wouldn't disagree with
that
good however I would disagree that you
can actually tell it from this
verse not not for any real reason but
doesn't look like it from that
particular verse yeah don't jump the gun
I'm GNA show it to you because you've
already established two facts number one
the spirit of God and God are there
number two you've established that the
verb hovering is used for an eagle that
has awareness and that's being liken to
God that God hovers over you that means
he has awareness but here's the other
evidence which Rabbi tried to explain
away and saying God is speaking to the
angels just before you do just just
before you do that you don't actually
need the verse to know that God or
indeed his Spirit which we which I don't
see as distinct from him as has
awareness from any particular verse you
don't need that all you need to know is
that God is God and therefore obviously
he has awareness and if his spirit is
him then of course that has awareness
too it's obvious no that's obvious
because You' let me finish the point
because I'm going to ask you who's God
speaking to and don't tell me the Angels
that's not going to work so if you were
patient Josh I know what you believe be
patient because in Genesis one he said
God God said let us make man our image
after our likeness so he's talking to
someone who he's going to involve in
creating and that's not Angels because
angels Don't create so who's he talking
to Josh no that's uh that's it's it's
it's not true because involving some now
hold on a second involving some
involving them in creation does not mean
that they're actually going to create
themselves sorry you want to bet it says
let us make man and image after our
likeness there's no need to talk in the
plural let us make man in our image and
our likeness if God Alone is creating
unless there's someone else involved in
the creation so don't give me a post Haw
explanation deal with unless unless it
is teaching us um the uh the the lesson
that a leader should always consult with
those beneath them
even if even if those beneath them are
not actually going to take take part in
the action don't give me your copot
rinic interpret I know your can you
argue with it you AR I'm gonna argue it
very easily go ahead be patient because
in Genesis 2:7 I'm going to show you who
the other entity was that God used to
create men be
patient take it easy I'm not your rabbis
who give this excuse I know what you're
going to say I know you're going to say
the voice what is the breath of life
that God breathe into the nostrils of
man what's the Breath of Life Breath of
Life what's the breath of life it's it's
the soul no right he breaths in the soul
no it comes in no the Breath of Life is
the breath that makes man alive yeah
exactly and that and that is the soul no
that is the Spirit hold on Josh let me
show you it's the soul I'm gonna use
your own books not me no it's the spirit
here I'm going to show you here you go
from your own tanak I didn't use the
Christian Bible here you go uh now here
who created man the spirit of God made
me and the breath of the almighty keeps
me alive so this is Hebrew parallelism
so see you Hebrew parallelism because I
don't know if the rabbis taught you that
yet okay I learned about this when I did
Biblical Hebrew AEL don't worry can you
tell me be patient so you can answer in
the second line the almighty corresponds
to who in the first line God because God
is the almighty oh good so the breath in
the second line corresponds to who in
the first line Spirit you just destroyed
your case and proved mine so the breath
is the spirit good job Josh no
yes no because because because in
Genesis 2 it doesn't it doesn't use the
word r it doesn't use the it doesn't it
says the Breath of Life irant irrelevant
irrelevant over there we only see we
only see the um the verb and he blew it
doesn't say he blew the spirit into him
it just says b here just
like let me respond to you take it easy
don't manifest Muslims manifest not you
you're not a Muslim take it easy just
like here it didn't say he blew the
spirit but we know the breath here is
the spirit from the parallel okay sure
but that's not the same that's not the
same you want to bet is the same let's
go oh man you're getting me tired
because I have to repeat myself I know
it's the same Because unless you believe
Genesis 1 and two are two different
creation accounts Genesis 1 already
prepared me to know who the breath is
because it starts
with so do you believe they're two
different creation accounts or they're
one in the same you're jumping oh my
goodness okay you are I GNA make it easy
for
you please explain to me please what
Genesis
1:2 has to do with with with the verse
in Genesis 2 I forgotten which very easy
because is Genesis 1 2 and 26 talking
about the spirit and the creation of man
in 26 it doesn't say the spirit created
man and you know it okay let's do this
this guy's Wast of our time in job it
says that in Genesis it doesn't say that
let's try it again it doesn't say that
God blew the listen to my argument
listen to my argument is Genesis 126
about the of man yeah of course okay but
hold on it says male and female he
created them now can you tell me the
order in which he created the male and
female just from Genesis one don't go to
Genesis 2 male male and female he C them
he C them together but in Genesis 2 it
says the male came first female came
later but you can't use that so reading
this is it the same creation account in
Genesis 2 yes okay I want everyone to
hear it because he's wasting time yeah
was time okay Josh let me explain how
you just admit Genesis 1 and two they're
talking about the same creation but one
will come and fill out the details so in
Genesis 1 if I have Genesis 1 it says he
created man male and female Genesis 2
then com fills it out first came the
male then the female but would you deny
it's the same God that created male and
female in Genesis God but wait hold on
here it says Elohim in Genesis 2 it says
I don't yes so but it doesn't use the
same name it says Hashem Elohim here
just eloh I've I explained that near the
beginning the different names of God are
merely different attributes of God the
different way refering to him are just
different aspects of him that wasn't my
objection buddy okay
me if everyone heard your logic you said
because in Genesis 2 it doesn't use the
word therefore it's not the Same Spirit
even though Genesis 2 is expanding on
what's in Genesis 1 so
I'm that's not actually what I mean
because it sounded like it sounded like
when you said and he when when it says
in Genesis 2 and go and and and he blew
into his nostrils the uh the the the
soul of life it doesn't say soul dude
stop saying Soul it says
breath Nish Nish means Soul no that word
there wasn't
we're not talking about we're talking
about the breath of life that's not what
it
says
okay and he blew and he
blew in his
nostrils you can keep preaching buddy I
want people I'm telling what the verse
says here here hold on Bible too oh my
goodness this guy can he's manifesting
like a job okay hold on okay hold on
dude okay okay blue all right okay hold
on let's
see what is uh nishma
lexically is the soul wait wait wait
wait read the lexican hold on I don't I
know the lexican says breath spirit and
soul and also puff wind anger vital
breath divine inspiration intellectual
and animal and then here in Deuter 2016
what's the word
here not allow
anything that's a very it's a very silly
translation translated anything that
what any anything that has a
soul you you shall not no you you shall
not let live any Soul that's what it
that's you said it's a silly translation
right okay hold on translation take it
easy bro it's transla as a verb when
it's clearly a
noun okay I don't know why it does that
okay I don't know yeah well hold on
let's see Rashi maybe he'll help you
let's see rashi rashi hold on let's go
we'll go to rashy hold on Buddy because
I'm trying to do all I can to get you to
say on topic but uh I'll work with you
I'll work with you come on Rashi help
this guy out Deuteronomy
2016 all right now he translated as Soul
right like you like it any Soul
okay hold on well you know what I should
give rashi's commentary hold on just I'm
GNA I'm gonna let Rashi help you out
hold on one second one second
[Music]
buddy okay he doesn't have a commentary
there good let's go now Genesis rash you
help this guy out because you know you
agree with him so they won't say I'm
bias all right it means Soul does it
mean breath okay all righty there whoa
there Nelly
okay
77 wait so how did Rashi uh translated
and he breathed into his nostrils the
soul
of no take it take it
easy can you take it easy let me finish
I'm help I'm letting him help you to
refute me take it easy I'm letting him
you refute me he made him of Earthly
matter and of heavenly matter the body
of Earthly matter the soul of heavenly
matter because on the first day Heaven
on the second day he created the firment
of the Heavenly beings on the third day
and let the dry land appear for the
Earthly beings on the fourth day he
created luminaries for the Heavenly
beings on the fifth all right we got
that for the Earthly and the six it
became necessary create for both
Heavenly and Earthly beings for if not
there would be jealousy in the creation
for these would exceed by these creation
one day so he doesn't really say much
okay so you and agree so I'm helping him
to help you okay so you're saying it's
the soul of life right yes okay now in
Genesis 2 I'm GNA turn against you just
be patient I promise you I will in
Genesis 2 these translations are all bad
we're going to go with yours in Genesis
2 do you agree that in Genesis 1 the
spirit played a role in
creation um played a role yeah right
here this right
here the
the only that that yeah I mean he was
hovering over the spirit of God was
hovering over the you agree okay do you
agree that in Genesis 2 it's expanding
on Genesis
1 it's it's fitting fitting in the
details of Genesis one and do you agree
that in Genesis 2 the god of Genesis one
is Hashem because you say Hashem of
Genesis 2 okay so now what I want to ask
you to consistency where do you find the
spirit in Genesis 2 what role does he
play in Genesis
2 he's not
mentioned I didn't ask just like you
believe Genesis is an expansion of
Genesis 1 and therefore it's filling out
the
details can you show me where the spirit
is mentioned and the specific role he
plays in the creation of man because job
33:4 says the spirit of God have made me
but according to you that's not Genesis
126 so don't do the tap dancece because
when God said let us make man that was
in the spirit Spirit and the breath is
not the spirit so where did job 334 get
that the spirit of God made man where do
you find that in Genesis 1 and2 because
it's hearkening back to Genesis 1 and
two I want you and Rashi to bail
yourself out of this one no okay let me
think for a second think
about so people understand what I'm
saying let me show you the verse
again unless you're saying job made it
up okay even a blind man can say that
job 33 for has in mind Genesis 1 and
Genesis 2 but according to you Genesis 2
the breath of life should be the soul of
life not breath because you want to tap
dance that's okay I'll tap dance with
you and Rashi I like to that I need to
lose weight so now where do you find in
Genesis 1 and2 that the spirit of God
made
man don't appeal to genesis6 because you
just said God wasn't speaking to the
spirit so where does it say in your
Torah the spirit made man show it to me
from Genesis
1 yeah and since you don't like the fact
that nishat was translated breath I'm
going to show you Psalm 3 let me go to
kabad okay now you want to see where the
spirit created the
Stars okay to prove my point that the
Breath of Life is the spirit that comes
out not the soul of man because I'm
gonna ask you another question but see I
told you I'm gonna let Rashi to help you
to refute me so I can take both you and
Rashi at the same time hold on I've uh
I've had a look I've consulted the I've
consulted the
malbim consulted malbim which is another
one of our commentaries I'm going to
with you I'm going to agree with you um
that that the specific aspect of uh of
God that created man was um was the uh
was the the spirit of God oh so I was
right after 15 minutes of wasting my
time I was right I had to look into it
first I hadn't come across that AR do
you know God was speaking to the spirit
no God wasn't speaking to the spirit the
who did they say speak man to let us
make man then no you're not gonna find
that in any of our commentaries that God
spoke to the spirit I know I'm not going
to find it in your commentaries because
your okay all right okay well
after 20 minutes to waste my time he
said I was right about the spirit creat
okay now my friend who made the host of
heaven what's the word breath don't tell
me it's because I know what it is but I
want you to tell me what is it that is
say it
again and the RO came out of
what PIV his mouth the breath of his
mouth just like the breath came out of
God's mouth that he
blue yeah oh and you don't see that the
breath of the spirit then
yeah with the breath of his mouth all
the host yeah okay but hold on hold on
no no that's not my point you wasted 20
minutes of my life and I'm not getting
younger but that's that's okay hold on
so when it says in Genesis
2:7 when God breathed the breath of life
that breath that came out of him I said
that's the spirit that gives life you go
no no the soul so now it says that the
ru comes out of his mouth isn't that Al
where the breath comes out from God's
mouth I mean based on this there's the
breath coming com out of his mouth the
comes from his mouth but it says so now
you can't play the game saying it's
meaning Soul so now if the comes out of
his mouth then when God breathes what is
he breathing out of
himself he's he's breathing the breath
out of himself what is that breath here
buddy the breath of his mouth so you
just admit is what say it again means
what breath only breath are we're gonna
play that game it means both oh so you
just now help me prove that what God
breathes out of his mouth is the very R
and spirit so why' you waste 20 minutes
of my time when you now agreed with
me well because I haven't come across
this argument before that's why oh okay
well now I want to show you something
from job all
right okay now we're going to go into
plural I need you to explain this to me
my friend okay first let's see job 3115
okay okay now it do can you confirm it
uses the word made us
both U hold on I can't on
mine yeah did not one form us both in
the wom like in the sh right sh yes
that's the
same okay now guys W okay now please
you'll break my heart if you lie to me I
swear I'll be BR broken if you lie to me
job
3510 3510 3510 hold on okay can you tell
us what the Hebrew is for my maker hold
on one second let me just get it
up um hold on one
second
3510 35
the word here
ooy ooy is what again my maker no no no
what is the form of Assa here is it
singular or plural
participle ah well it's either pual or
plural because it's got the
so it could be actually a paal Al I know
you're going to say it's plural no I'm
not going to say anything anyway so I'm
going to go with that let's say it's
plural okay plural okay I'm not going to
go with it here I want everyone to see
here it
says Cal form participle masculine
plural construct yeah mascul masculine
plural so okay but you're going to go
with me that it's plural yeah I'll okay
with that it doesn't really affect me
okay so if it's plural then let's go
with plural like you said you would so
it's my what maker or
makers uh in the same way that we
translate mean literally means owners in
the singular owner um yeah we translate
this hold on what did you translate I
didn't hear you in the same way that in
Exodus when it talks about a specific
owner it says it in the plural
but no that that's wrong because in
Exodus 251 21
5-6 you're assuming that he's being
presented before his ruler as opposed to
being a witness before God that he's
selling himself into Perpetual servitude
to his master that's an assumption I'm
not talking about because by the way
Orthodox Jews they don't like to
pronounce God's name they'll say Hashem
or they'll say Elohim that's not what I
was saying I was talking about what are
you referring to I was I was talking
about hold on let me just get up the
verse hold on okay is that Exodus all
right now hold on a second hold
on hold on a
second sorry I thought you referring to
because you said an owner and a yeah
hold on a
second I'm wrong it's not in uh in it's
not Exodus I'm WR hold on a second see
if I can find the verse hold on see if I
can find Ecclesiastes where would you
list it
guys we got a total of 3,300 people
watching from Sam's Channel and my
channel 2 200 here so let's make sure we
get the likes up guys we're not even at
a thousand likes right now what's going
on
James James Rogers you're a liar Son Of
Satan there was no debate about the
Trinity for Century stop lying go ahead
go ahead my friend goad yeah let's get
the light up hold on one second before
you read
if you go to judges J right before you
read can you hear me Josh yeah go ahead
Josh if you go to Judges chapter
hello hold on hold on a second we can
hear you ay he can hear you but he's
he's telling me where to go we can hear
you what's going on okay you go to
Judges chapter 2 verse 11 we'll go there
we'll go to judges hold on one second
Judes okay yeah I was just addressing
the audience here guys we need to get
the likes up man let's get the likes up
to 2,000 on the on the channel um and
Sam Sam you got almost a thousand people
watching over there so everybody
watching guys hit the like button it
helps push the streams okay so everybody
hit the like button from both if you
watching from both hit the like button
on both all right all right yeah I know
what he's referring to yes I do
understand that there will be plural
nouns used for singular subjects but
that wasn't my argument this is not a
plural noun it's a plural participle
it's a verbal adjective that's different
than using nouns in the plural I'm aware
of this okay I'm aware of that we're
talking because you're talking about now
verbs plural participles this is a
verbal adjective so I know that plural
nouns can be used for singular subjects
my argument isn't simply that it's
plural participles not just plural nouns
and plural pronouns now for example
Ecclesiastes 121 can you tell us what
the word here for bar
is I can't see it on there because it's
not there so I have to get it on
mine let me it's zoomed in too much so
I'll get it online you want me to zoom
I'll zoom in down hold on hold on one
second I'll bring it down for you I've
almost got it Ecclesiastes chapter you
got it right there here I've got it now
okay b
e b yes it's it's got the Y there
meaning say it again it's got the Y
there b e plural yeah plural so
literally it's remember you're creators
right in a literal way way but again we
don't we don't so job 3510 it's
literally if I translate literally okay
my makers your creators creators so it's
plural
right yeah it's it's it's written in the
plural it many times it's written in the
plural many times no not many times when
it comes to yeah many times many times I
can show times
[Music]
when I know my brethen Humanity plural
verbs plural participles are used for
plural subjects rarely will you find it
if at all for a singular subject I'm not
talking about plural nouns I'm not
talking about plural nouns
likeon plural verbs plural
participles are rarely if at all used
for singular subjects so I sorry what
you don't seem to quite understand is
that there isn't really a clear
distinction in Biblical Hebrew grammar
between participles and nouns there
isn't actually a clear distinction
between them yeah I know you have to say
that that's fine no it's it's true
example for example how do you say a
Creator you say Bor how do you say one
who creates the same word b right it's
it's exactly the same word so B you
could translate it either way right
because because all
participles are in fact
nouns what a participle is brother
Humanity in the context when a word is
used as a noun like a descriptive noun
common noun it will be clear like ELO
well I don't want to offend you but I
can say Elohim but when you want to use
that noun in a way that's either showing
an action not a noun then there's a way
that can be written to make it singular
or plural so now what would be the
singular of my
Creator um my Creator would be b e so
why wasn't it then placed in the
singular you mean you mean your creator
it would be um B yeah you're your
creator okay let's go to your how do you
say your creator in singular
singular and how do you say it in the
plural I can't even hear your accent
e okay and how
I agree with you that's what it says
here I'm saying words the distinction
you're making in Biblical Hebrew nouns
and participles doesn't really exist
okay but brother in humanity you just
admit there's a singular form of this
word it didn't have to be in the plural
right yes so why are we arguing when
you're confirming every point I'm making
I don't get it you just because when I
brought up when I brought up um the
point about about about Bim um you said
that uh that um that that's different
because those are nouns was these are
participles I'm saying that distinction
isn't really real no it is real because
if you heard what I said we can tell
from the text whether it's being used as
a
noun like if I say Adon or if it's being
used in the context not as a noun but as
a verbal adjective that was my point it
that's why I say when it's being used
you can I think they always
mean I swear I don't want to waste time
I'll con not wasting time I think this
is an important I don't want to waste
time because I want to now ask you
another thing
Genesis okay we're going to Jacob yeah
okay
now what does Jacob say their God had
been revealed to me yeah what is the
Hebrew for revealed to me again of
course it's in the
plural now here's for sure a verb yeah
okay say it again it's what it's it's a
plural
verb so if I were to say to the audience
literally it says their God they had
been revealed to me they had been
revealed to me that to him they had been
revealed to him yeah they had been
revealed who's they God but of course
which is also plural so there you go but
I'm want to show you hold on what see
brother I know it's why it's plural
because right here it's going to tell
you why there's a distinction can you
explain why in verse one it says Elohim
said to Jacob arise and go up to bethl
and abide there and make an altar to e
who appeared to you now here it's plural
Elohim but then it says Jacob go honor
the E who appeared to you at bethl do
you see the difference of course I see
the difference okay so now Elohim is
plural I'm going to show you why in a
minute but then it says doesn't say go
make an altar to the Elohim will appear
to you it says go to make an altar to
the E singular appear to you why that
distinction do you want do you want my
answer please give it to me I want to
hear it out go ahead right the my answer
which is the traditional rinic answer is
that the beginning where it says Elohim
refers to God in his strict um in his
strict um mode of judgment and the word
and the word kale um which is the
shortened version is refers to God as um
as a uh as as a in his in his aspect of
kindness and therefore God in his aspect
of judgment in strict Justice is
speaking to Jacob and he says arise and
go up to bethl and abide there and make
there an altar to to God in his aspect
of kindness who appeared to you when you
fled from your brother oh okay so if I
show you where the word Elohim is used
in reference to God being merciful and
compassionate what would you say then
then there's an explanation as to why
over there judgment even though it looks
like Mercy okay guys did you guys catch
it right yeah I want you to hear what he
just said he's not deriving from the
texts he's interpreting it in light of
what rabic Judaism says and he thinks
we're gonna accept it that's fine I'm
expecting you to accept it okay but
you're here you're trying to refute me
from proving the Trinity and you'll of
course you want you got to refute me you
and for me to see the a of my way you're
not you're actually actually so far
you've proved my case but just to sum up
why your explanation not going to make
sense I'm going to show you number one
guys he admit this says Elohim said to
Jacob arise and go up to bethl and abide
there and make there an altar to e
singular who appeared to you when you
fled from your brother Esau then he
admits I just want people remind what
you just admitted he built there an
altar and he called the place e be I'm
saying so it doesn't sound like the
letter L be God of the house of God for
there Elohim they had been revealed to
him he admits had been revealed to him
it's plural so literally they had been
revealed to him now I'm going to show
you why it's plural not your explanation
I'm going to show you from tanak you
ready sure all
right actually more than one God how do
we know what how do we know it's
actually plural it's actually more than
one God it's not just one no because
when we say that God is one it means
that even though there's a plurality
it's not a plurality of gods but Divine
persons that make up God because I don't
expect Hebrew to use modern terminology
for
precision okay now here's the answer why
Elohim said Elohim said Jacob when you
go back to Beth build an ALT to the E
who appeared to you here's the answer
buddy Genesis 31:10
to13 and it came to pass at the time the
animals came into heat that I lifted up
my eyes and saw in a dream and behold
the he goats that mounted the animals
were ring speckled and striped an angel
of God said to me in a dream Jacob and I
said here I am and he said now lift your
eyes and see that all he gos mounting
the animals are ring speckled and
striped for I have seen all that lean is
doing to you I am the god of bethl
who who's the god of
bethl God is the god of bethl okay let's
try it again an angel of God said to me
in a dream Jacob angel of God I know
what you're saying you want to prove
from this that therefore the angel of
God is God because he speaks as if he is
God I would like to refute you on this
let prove it and refute you because your
attention to Deuteronomy chapter
29 because in Deuteronomy chapter
29 yeah I know I'm waiting for you to
make so I can refute it go ahead I'm
gonna let you have says Moses summoned
all Israel and said to them you have
seen all that Hashem did before your
very eyes in the land of Egypt to f and
to all his courtiers and his whole
country the wondrous Feats that you saw
with your own eyes th those prodigious
signs and Marvels yet to this day God
has not given you a mind to understand
or eyes to see or hears or ears to hear
I led to the through of the Wilderness
40 years the cloth on your back did not
wear out nor did the sandals on your
feet you had no bread to eat and no wine
or other intoxicant to drink you may
know that I am Hashem your God is Moses
God no of course not no one I respond to
you because I knew you're going to go
see you think I don't know your
arguments number one the context makes
clear that God is speaking through Moses
so that the speak speakers can collapse
so that Moses doesn't have to say God
said because you already started the
narrative by Moses telling you it's God
Speaking In this passage that I gave you
it didn't have the angel of God saying
thus says the
Lord this is what the Lord says to you J
up it's a false analogy so do say that
there either it doesn't say thus said
the Lord Moses doesn't say that you just
read it that Hashem said Hashem did so
he already began by identifying Hashem
he starts by ref God in the third person
and then he refers to God in the first
person as if he is God did you hear okay
repeat my objection let's see if you
understood my objection your objection
is that over there the context makes it
clear that um that Moses is quoting God
I would ask argue that that's clear
every time that the angel quotes God no
that's where I'm now going to bring my
second objection to be your argument
Genesis 48:15 to6 see buddy I've heard
your arguments you haven't heard mine
you should have spent time reading and
watching my rebuttal so you be better
prepared no because here Jacob is
blessing his
grandchildren and he blessed Joseph and
said God before my fathers Abraham and
Isaac walked God who sustained me as
long as I'm my life until this day May
the angel who redeemed me from all harm
bless the use now the verb bless is it
plural or singular singular who's
blessing the grandchildren God wants the
angel so Jacob wants the angel to bless
the youths and who redeemed Jacob from
all
his all the evil the angel so why did he
Begin by mentioning God of Abraham and
ISAC God he's talking to God and ask
he's talking to the children and he's
using the same language God before my
fathers Abraham and Isaac walked God who
sustained his long as I alive until this
day the angel he's using the same speech
for God and the angel so I'm gonna ask
you the
question it's a prayer did you let me
finish the point or you getting excited
all right I I'll God he's praying to God
but all of a
sudden he uses the singular verb may he
bless what happened to God he forgot
about God he started with God but ends
up with the angel blessing them so
where's your God in this prayer he's
he's asking he's asking God to get the
angel to bless that's not what it says
stop distorting the Hebrew he's speaking
God God angel may he he didn't ask God
to have the angel blessed he's
speaking to his grandchildren and
invoking the angel to bless he didn't
say God can you have the angel bless
them stop butchering the Hebrew dude he
not butchering the Hebrew at
first then he addresses the angel say it
again first he addresses God then he
addresses the angel so why is it then
singular verb why isn't it
plural at that point he's just
addressing the angel so he forgot about
God all of a sudden forget about God
he's just not addressing him at this
point no you know why because the god of
Abraham is the Angel who said I'm the
god of bethl no I'm quoting your tanak
and all you can say is no all right how
about because because okay answer me
this why would it be that the messenger
of God I because that's what the word
Mal literally means a messenger why
would it be that God's messenger is God
that doesn't even make sense because God
tells us he is God in Exodus 23 I'm
going I'm already anticipating you
brother take it easy man the messenger
of God isn't God because the messenger
of God is a messenger guys notice
messenger it's not
me buddy but if you're my messenger
messenger and you're human I'm human
does that mean because you're my
messenger you're not
human no so wait wait you're the
messenger of me and because you're not
me that means you're not human because
I'm human and you're not me so you're
not human no that a double negative
that's exactly your logic because the
messenger is not the god that sent him
but he has the nature of God that's why
we say that Old Testament teaches the
trinity
here no okay just read messenger of God
is a vehicle for God to speak to people
like just like Moses just like mes okay
can you show me then where it says of
Moses May Moses Bless The Lads or my
name is in
Moses let me get there
buddy here Exodus 23223 I'm going to
show you how your rabbis had a problem
with this passage because they had a
problem with the fact that Joshua
worshiped him I want to get it to you
wait just be patient Exodus 23
20-23 behold I'm sending Angel before
you to guard your way on you on the way
and to bring you to the place that I
prepared beware of him and Obey him do
not rebel against him for he will not
forgive your transgression for my name
is in him who is this messenger that has
God's name in him embodying the name of
God who can forgive sins or punish you
who is this guy he doesn't need a name
he's a he's a messenger of God he's an
angel doesn't need my name is within him
bu it's in front of me right so so when
when God's name is within the angel that
means there's an added level of divinity
that uh that means that that we have to
respect him more than a regular Angel wa
wait wait I want repeat that added level
of what of of divinity guys he just
admit that the angel is divine no an
added level of divinity within the angel
doesn't mean the angel itself is divine
wait hold on if Divinity is in him then
that means he's not Divine yeah I love
your logic I didn't say if Divinity is
within him that means he's not Divine I
said if Divinity is not with him it is
if div if if Divinity is within him that
does not mean that he is divine you want
to bet that's because God is explain God
is explaining why he can forgive sins or
punish you please don't tell me he will
not forgive your transgression okay
watch here see I knew you're gonna do
that see buddy I'm a chess player okay
take it easy man I'm going to show you
that it means if you don't obey him
he'll punish you but if you obey him
he'll forgive you take it E I knew
you're goingon to say this argument but
here's your burial Zechariah 3: 3 to 4
the angel has the power to forgive sins
here Zechariah 3: 3 to 4 now Joshua was
wearing filthy garments standing before
the angel and he now this is your
translation buddy so you know who the he
is the Angel raised his voice and said
to those standing before him saying take
the filthy garments off of him and he
said to him see I have removed your
iniquity from you and I've CLA clad you
with clean garments how does the angel
forgive sins buddy it's right there in
front of
you yeah that's what I thought it's uh
it's it's a
vision hey boss do you want to come back
because we' we entertain you but we have
other people come back we'll have more
conversation all right fine Josh
seriously you're more than welcome to
come back man all right do you have a uh
do you have a way I could contact you
yeah uh yeah I'll put an email address
in the and we'll have more conversation
about the trinity in the Hebrew
scriptures and then about Messianic
prophecy I want to talk about Messianic
prophecy that even Rashi admits is about
Messiah and then we can talk about your
two Messiahs Messiah Ben Joseph who will
be killed and Messiah Ben David so let's
come back and talk about let's set it up
sometime this week uh okay I put my
email address in the chat so if you want
to get in touch yes so next conversation
I want to talk about your rabbis talking
about two Messiahs Messiah Ben Joseph
will be killed fulfilling Zechariah
12:10 because you don't like to tell
people that you do believe in a messiah
who will be killed right I I've told
people this on many occasions you me
before good we'll talk about it then
Isaiah 53 where your toia singer tries
to deny its Messianic implication but
admits it in other places but we'll talk
we'll reach out to you all right all
right buddy all right take care man
thanks for coming get in contact yes
bring them up next time we'll do it next
time on Messianic will I definitely will
all right